♪♪
>> Dagen: WE KNOW WHY PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS BEEN TO THE BORDER.
HE'S WAY TOO BUSY?
>> DO YOU PLANS TO I HAVE HAVE
IT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
I HAVE BEEN THERE BEFORE.
I KNOW IT WELL.
I GUESS I SHOULD GO DOWN.
BUT THE WHOLE POINT OF IT IS, I
HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF TIME TO GET
DOWN.
I'VE BEEN SPENDING TIME GOING
AROUND, LOOKING AT 900 BILLION
OF DAMAGE DONE BY HURRICANES AND
FLOODS AND WEATHER AND TRAVELING
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT I PLAN ON -- MY WIFE JILL
HAS BEEN DOWN.
>> Dagen: OH, GOOD.
THE WHITE HOUSE GOT TESTY AFTER
BEING PRESSED ON BIDEN'S CLIMB
THAT HE HAS VISITED IN THE PAST
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE.
>> PETER, AS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN,
THERE'S BEEN REPORTING THAT HE
DID DRIVE THROUGH THE BORDER
WHEN HE WAS ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL IN 2008 AND HE'S CERTAINLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE FACT AND IT
STUCK WITH THEM, THE FACT THAT
IN EL PASO, THE BORDER GOES
RIGHT THROUGH THE CENTER OF
TOWN.
>> DOES THAT COUNT AS A VISIT?
HE SAID I'VE BEEN THERE BEFORE.
YOU'RE SAYING HE DROVE BY FOR A
FEW MINUTES?
DOES THAT COUNT?
>> WHAT IS THE ROOT CAUSE?
WHERE ARE PEOPLE COMING FROM
THAT ARE COMING TO THE BORDER,
PEOPLE?
>> Dagen: GREG, SHE BLAMED
TRUMP.
HE DROVE THROUGH THE BORDER.
50 YEARS IN POLITICS AND HE
DROVE THROUGH.
>> Greg: DOES THAT COUNT?
I ACTUALLY WENT TO TURKEY ONCE
BECAUSE I HAD A CONNECTION
THERE.
YOU EVER DO THAT?
YOU COUNT WHERE YOU'VE BEEN --
>> Kennedy: A STATE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
NO, I JUST WENT TO THE GIFT SHOT
AND WAITING FOR MY NEXT FLIGHT.
PART OF ME SAYS THE LESS HE
DOES, THE BETTER.
HE'S STILL DOING STUFF.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
IF HE WAS A BUMBLING CONSULTANT
HIRED BECAUSE HE'S YOUR UNCLE'S
BEST FRIEND, THAT WOULD BE FINE.
BUT HE'S IN CHARGE OF STUFF.
I SHOULD BE HAPPY THAT THE
COUNTRY IS ON AUTO PILOT BUT
MAYBE IT'S NOT ON AUTO PILOT.
MAYBE THERE'S SOMEBODY IN THE
COCKPIT AND DRIVING THIS PLANE
INTO THE GROUND.
MAYBE THEY ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
>> Dagen: IT'S SOMEBODY IN THE
GALLY NIPPING AT THE SAUCE AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE COCKPIT.
WHY WOULD HE GO AT THIS POINT?
HE WILL BE GREETED BY THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRYING TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS OF THE COUNTRY.
THE BORDER PATROL VILIFIED
FALSELY BY BIDEN, BORDER PATROL
AND HORSEBACK, ALL OF THE
RANCHERS THAT ARE NOW PACKING
HEAT WHEREVER THEY GO BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE LIKE SWARMING OVER
THEIR LAND.
HE WOULD GET CHANTS OF "LET'S GO
BRANDON" FOR SURE.
>> Jessica: A GOOD FRIDAY LAUGH,
KENNEDY.
GOING TO THE BORDER, MAKING
IMMIGRATION -- THIS IS EXACTLY
FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER -- IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT DEMOCRATS
TEND TO DO.
THAT'S A FACT.
IT'S NOTHING THAT THEY WANT TO
RUN ON.
IT'S BEEN FOR DECADES.
DONALD TRUMP LOVED GOING TO THE
BORDER.
HE'S GOING THERE SINCE HE HASN'T
BEEN PRESIDENT AND HE DOESN'T GO
TO PLACES HE DOESN'T WANT TO GO.
HE DOESN'T SHOW UP IN FLINT
MICHIGAN TO TALK ABOUT THE WATER
QUALITY.
HE --
>> Jesse: HE HAS GONE TO CHICAGO
WHEN THEY WERE IN CHICAGO.
HE SHOULD HAVE GONE AND SEEN THE
SOUTH SIDE.
HE DOES EVENTS LIKE HE SAID --
>> Jessica: HE'S ONLY BEEN IN
THE OFFICE FOR EIGHT MONTHS.
>> Jesse: HE SHOULD HAVE DROVE
TO MEXICO TO DO A POLITICAL
EVENT AND FLEW OUT.
THAT'S GOING TO THE BORDER?
>> Jessica: THAT'S YOUR
PRIORITY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU THINK --
>> Jesse: THE COUNTRY'S
PRIORITY.
>> Jessica: IT'S NOT THE NUMBER
1 PRIORITY.
>> Jesse: IT'S THE NUMBER 2
ISSUE FACING THIS COUNTRY.
YOU'RE A POLSTER.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT.
>> Greg: ARE YOU A POLSTER?
>> Jesse: SHE IS.
>> Greg: I HAD NO IDEA.
SHE'S PREGNANT.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS BAD GREG.
WHERE IS GOOD GREG?
>> Dagen: DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE TO SAY?
>> Jesse: IT'S FUNNY HE SAYS
HE'S TOO BUSY TO GO TO THE
BORDER.
HE'S BEEN TO CAMP DAVID TEN
TIMES, DAGEN.
HE'S BEEN TO AN INTERNATIONAL
TRIPS ONCE.
THIS WEEK HE HAD A THREE-DAY
WEEK.
HE TOOK OFF FRIDAY AND MONDAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING.
HE DOESN'T DO ANYTHING.
TRUMP WENT SOMEWHERE.
AIR FORCE ONE SITTING ON THE
TARMAC LONELY HAS HELL.
I FEEL BAD FOR AIR FORCE ONE.
COME SIT ON ME, JOE.
THAT'S ALL AIR FORCE ONE SAYS.
ALL HE WANTS TO DO IS GO TO
SCRANTON AND MICHIGAN.
THERE'S OTHER STATES TO GO TO.
>> Kennedy: OH, HE SHOULD GO TO
THE BORDER.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO HUMAN
BEINGS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IS
AWFUL AND CRUEL.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S SIGNED A BUNCH OF
IMMIGRATION EXECUTIVE ORDERS
THAT HE BACKTRACKED ON.
HE'S RELYING ON THE TRUMP
IMMIGRATION POLICY THAT IS LIKE
LEG HUMPING.
I SAID THAT BECAUSE MY DOG --
>> Jesse: ONE OF HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDERS WAS TO GET BACK AT TRUMP.
THAT'S ALL IT WAS.
POLICE CALL, EMOTIONAL --
>> Kennedy: YOU KNOW WHAT THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY IS
COGENT.
LET'S USE THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE A POLICY.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
THEY SHOULD HAVE A PLAN.
THEY HAVE THE VOTES.
THEY CAN DO SOMETHING ON
IMMIGRATION.
IF THEY DON'T GET THIS BILL
PASSED, STREAMLINE THE SYSTEM SO
PEOPLE CAN HUMANELY ENTER THIS
COUNTRY SO THEY'RE NOT PASSING
THROUGH PARTS OF CENTRAL AMERICA
TO ALMOST CERTAIN DEATH AND IN
MANY CASES WITH KIDS
UNACCOMPANIED BEING SEXUALLY
ABUSED.
IT'S AWFUL.
THEY NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS --
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE THINGS ON
TOP OF INFLATION, THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AND AFGHANISTAN WHERE THEY
PREEBB TEND EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
IT'S NOT GREAT.
IT'S HORRIBLE.
>> Dagen: I WAS SURPRISED BIDEN
WAS NOT PREPARED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AND DID A CRAP JOB OF
ANSWERING IT DESPITE ANDERSON
COOPER FEEDING HIM PUREED FOOD.
>> Jesse: DR. JILL HAS BEEN DOWN
THERE, BAY AGAIN.
WHEN YOUR WIFE GOES --
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, SHE'S A
MEDICAL DOCTOR.
SHE WAS PROBABLY THERE TREATING
PATIENTS.
>> Jessica: I'M HAVE THE SAME
DEGREE AND I'M A POLST